arnaud vous êtes co fondateur du
collectif prévenir et protéger qui vise
à défendre les enfants victimes d'abus
sexuels et si vous vous engagez si vous
avez été vous même victime d'abus
sexuels de la part de votre compte tu en
prends ton qui était prêtre
vous avez été violé notre l'âge de 8 et
11 ans par votre grand oncle comme je
les dis prêtre missionnaire
comment cet homme a pu se retrouver dans
votre chambre alors je vais peut-être
première chose j'ai effectivement été
violée je reviens juste sur un terme
pour mac est important parle pas de
pédophilie pas d'abus en parle de
pédocriminalité parce qu'on n'aime pas
les enfants de cette manière là c'est
important de le dire de manière fort est
ce un crime et c'est pour ça que la
question la non-dénonciation se pose
comment les choses se sont passées comme
pour beaucoup d'enfants finalement
certains enfants dira sa confiance en un
adulte c'était votre vie à un oncle est
par ailleurs un enfant bah on sait qu'un
rapport de force qui est pas du tout
équilibrées donc c'est un grand oncle
qui était prêtre missionnaire qui
étaient en afrique j'ai su par la suite
qui s'étaient déplacés étonnamment de
pays en pays et c'est un breton qui
continuait en france ces journées sur
mes parents qui habitaient pas loin de
l'aéroport de roissy mes parents leur
faisait
confiance enfin lui faisait confiance
pardon et du coup ils venaient dormir
dans ma chambre en fête le soir c'est
une période où je faisais encore par
moments pitié aux lignes de les
numériser comme on dit et ce grand tout
me venait me demander en fait au moins
ça se passait de venir le rejoindre dans
son lit voilà et puis petit à petit mais
expliqué au début
comment comment mon corps fonctionne et
il le présente être cette manière là je
suis assez crûment un peu dans le
témoignage parce que ce que je souhaite
c'est que j'aimerais vous avez raison il
faut pas seulement parce que plus plus
vous allez être sûrs et plus vraiment
frappé les histoires va frapper les a
prises directes et c'est ce qu'on sait
ce dont on a besoin en ce moment et
c'est pour ça qu'on en direct c'est pour
ça que j'ai un peu en colère sur la
manière dont on peut des fois réagir sur
ce sujet la nation qu'il me présentais
ça comme une découverte de mon corps
après très rapidement il disait que ça
pouvait servir à autre chose d'une
certaine manière on est d'accord j'avais
8 ans un habitant un enfant je le
rappelle n'a pas de sexualité pas de
sexualité de l'adulte et c'est essentiel
et puis de cette découverte l'a donc de
mon corps on allait vers une découverte
sexuelle et de la découverte sexuelle ou
finalement j'ai compris sur le moment il
faut bien comprendre qu'à huit ans
j'étais tétanisée et j'ai même cru
comprendre pendant tout un temps que
j'étais responsable de ce qui se passe
c'est parce que finalement c'était
inexplicable pour moi ça c'est ça un
événement complètement dingue fou c'est
souvent dans tous les témoignages et les
enfants culpabiliser c'est ce que vous
nous dites là où ça fait des enfants
culpabiliser et et en fin de compte ça a
été moins je le dis jusqu'à 1 bat juge
jusqu'à la sodomie assez important c'est
à dire qu'il a pu être est
systématiquement à chaque passage voilà
c'est chose qui se passait jamais
compris par exemple pour commencer à
démarrer là parce qu'on si arnaud donc
la première fois donc comme vous dites
vous faisais pipi au lit donc il vous
disait viens plutôt dans mon lit voilà
ça commence par les attouchements
finalement serre qui montre parce
qu'effectivement j'ai été souillés donc
j'étais déjà ça l'a donc forcément il y
avait ce côté là déjà pas propre
sûrement et du coup lui en profiter pour
bat pour pour toucher mon sexe pour
prendre ça ma main pour dire que par la
suite bah voilà le sexe grandira et c
est que je puisse mettre effectivement
ma main sur le sur son sexe etc enfin
voilà des choses qui sont complètement
passés d état de sidération
après trois ans ça a duré en fait chacun
de ses passages entre l'âge de 8 ans
nous voilà je me rappelle moi de cinq
fois après c'est toujours compliqué on
parle beaucoup de l'amnésie traumatique
sert cette mémoire qui est très
compliqué pour les victimes et qu'on a
tendance une certaine manière a oublié
du débat public mais celle qui fait en
fait qu'on sera pas l'unique man
certains flash soyez avec pour moi des
moments qui sont forcément extrêmement
extrêmement violent qui marque toute une
vie c'est pour ça que j'y tiens c'est à
dire que l'on peut me dire ce qu'on veut
alors aujourd'hui je suis papa il ya
plein de choses que je vise c'est
qu'elle joue bien j'ai 40 ans voilà on
n'a pas aujourd'hui tu veux papa d'un
petit garçon j'ai une belle films
vos parents se douter de rien du tout
mes parents se douter de rien et je même
vous dire voyez la première réaction ma
mère a marqué j'ai compris j'ai mis plus
de vingt ans en fait à va comprendre
mairie dit quand je vous ai dit j'avais
19 ans donc à 10 ans vend plus de dix
ans après les faits devant un reportage
en fait à la télé c'est pour ça que je
pense que la télé a de ce point de vue
là est salutaire parce que a fait partie
les journalistes font leur boulot aussi
part à trois ça pour que la parole se
libère et puisque la parole libérée nous
on a besoin d'avoir ce sont des actions
et ma mère la première réaction qu'elle
a eue c'était de dire
ça a été de dire ah mince j'avais 19 ans
pour regarder un reportage
est au bout de donc de de 11 ans vous
dites à votre mère en regardant ce
reportage comment vous lui dites oui
dites moi aussi je lui dis c'est
exactement ce qui est en fait ça sort
tout seul comme pour beaucoup de
victimes finalement baissé un peu le
flash et je lui dis
c'est ce qui m'est arrivé est ma mère de
manière un pouce finalement spontanée
dit on s'est fait avoir voilà ce que je
voulais dire voyez toute la confiance
qu'elle pouvait avoir en cet homme là
qui était également un grand oncle elle
même la comprenais pas c'était d'une
violence inouïe joly avait raconté
annuel si tu en sais faire c'est à dire
qu'elle comprenait pas comment ce que je
pouvais livré un témoignage comme celui
là mais comme beaucoup de parents
certains effets de sidération et moi
j'ai compris 20 ans plus tard réellement
ce qu'elle entendait par là parce que
c'est violent d'avoir sa mère qui réagit
comme ça c'est en leur promettant on
peut dire la première action ça pour
être de me prendre dans ses bras quelque
chose comme ça et le on s'est fait avoir
c'est que je suis convaincu aujourd'hui
c'est important voyez vous parlez de
libération de la parole les parents
l'ensemble du système de l'agresseur est
victime de de l'agresseur en tant que
tel et c'est pour ça que quand on parle
finalement de la parole libérée que
c'est parce que ça nous arrange bien je
dis que certaine manière il ya pas que
la parole des victimes et il ya des co
victime en fait de tout ça parce qu'il
ya un effet de sidération complet face à
quelque chose qui est atroce qui est
inimaginable et dont on a peine prendre
et c'est pour ça que moi j'emploie des
mots crus comme des mots comme sodomie
et c'est parce que c'est exactement la
violence de ce qui se passait il faut
bien se rendre compte qu'un parent
jamais imaginé son
employé ces mots crus si avec votre
maman quand vous guerrier non je vais
pas les employés comme ça parce qu'on
fait tout un travail de plus de 20 ans
de f1 de 20 ans de chant encore dedans
on va dire de psychothérapie parce qu'il
faut du temps je demande pour mettre ses
mots et parce que être accompagnés à
voir un psy ça permet à mon sens de
mieux comprendre aussi ce qui s'est
passé et de se rappeler en fait
l'ensemble de la stratégie de
l'agresseur et à l'âge de 8 ans il était
impossible de parler pour vous
n'arriviez pas à aller voir vos parents
alors dit voilà ce qui s'est passé dès
la première fois en fait vous comprenez
pas je pense que j'ai compris par la
suite qu'en fait vous n'êtes pas
structuré en fait le sans lien en fait
ça m'a complètement brisée parce que
c'est en se développant dans des
cantines et c'est elle je pars qu'est-ce
que quand quand vous le voyez on
s'imagine tout on se dit quand ils
devaient partir vous deviez avoir un
soulagement énorme et quand il revenait
à la maison et vous dire mais ça va être
le cauchemar va reprendre mais à quelque
chose qu'on maîtrise plus de soin en
fait réellement con ça vous arrive c'est
à dire qu'il ya quelque chose qui fait
qu'à un moment donné vous ce qu'on
appelle en fait un état de dissociation
que vous sortez de votre corps envoyer
c'est plus compliqué que ça c'est à dire
qu'il ya quelque chose en fait qui fait
toute la question de l'agresseur on
pense souvent que l'agresseur ben en
fait contraintes physiquement et en fin
de compte c'est faux bien souvent fait
l'agresseur arrive à créer en fait cet
état de sidération sera la victime et
n'a pas besoin de faire usage de la
force du coup il ya toute une atmosphère
une certaine heure qui est créé pour
qu'il arrive à ses fins et cette
atmosphère c'est aussi dans le lien pour
moi il ya un abus de confiance évident
au c'ur de mes parents et pour parvenir
justement à cette fin alors arnaud juste
vous avez vous avez sept autres 8 ans et
11 ans comment vous avez fait pour vivre
votre votre enfance vous avez réussi
voilà à vivre voilà l'idée avec vos
potes après avec vos petits copains ça
comment ça se passe parce que il s'est
passé onze ans comme vous me la bouille
et à vos parents que quittant ça se
passe comment on vit ça se passe qu'on y
pense et que surtout dans les premières
années avant même de comprendre
justement un peu plus tard ce qui
s'était passé on culpabilise moi j'avais
le sentiment encore dans la culture a
bien sûr et puis c'est la même chose sur
ma sexualité moi j'avais j'étais
persuadé d'être homosexuel par exemple
je sais pas différentes choses en me
disant c'est peut-être une question
d'attirant j'en sais rien faire parce
que c'est un 8 ans quand
et
puis forcément c'est compliqué et puis
après j'ai eu effectivement j'ai compris
petit à petit ce qui s'était passé voilà
je grâce à des aussi à des rencontres
autant passer aussi avec des psys parce
qu'il y avait forcément quelque chose
qui était mal j'étais dans une forme de
dépression moi je rappelle ici c'est
important si aujourd'hui je lutte contre
ce fléau massif qu'on a tendance à
banaliser faut savoir que vous avez une
enquête qui a été menée en 2014 on
appelle l' enquête virage qui dit que
vous avez 38% des personnes qui bien 38
% des personnes qui ont été violées
avant l'âge de 11 ans qui font une
tentative de suicide voilà c'est la
réalité c'est l'arrêté des chiffres ses
skis et nécessite qu'on parle de crime
et qu'on soit en capacité d'agir avec
toute la question aussi de la santé
publique et qu'on voudrait h 10 à la
hauteur de la gravité des actes alors
vous parler d'autorité depuis le début
le fait que votre oncle soient aussi
prêts que ça a ajouté une autorité plus
supplémentaires bien sûr surtout que ça
me fait un prêtre missionnaire qui
travaille auprès d'enfants du coup il
est temps dans quelque chose où tout le
monde lui disait c'est super il sait
bien s'occuper des enfants ouais c'était
géré pensionnaire de toutes les victimes
qui ont dû
toutes ces victimes vous ne devez pas
être le seul vous avez dû penser à ça
vous avez bien sûr c'est ça c'est bien
dans ce cas c'est mai encore oui c'est
ce qui m'a mis d'ailleurs dans la
démarche au niveau de la vo niveau de la
cciad dans le rapport est dans le rythme
notamment une autre victime jamais
jamais jamais mais j'ai su que je sais
qu'il a été dans certains pays est
effectivement je me dis que c'est
internationale c'est pour ça qu'en c'est
là qu'on se dit c'est là qu'on dit on
pense à toutes ces victimes vous dites
38 % des enfants qui subissent dès dvd
voilà les sévices sexuels pas suffi si
d'après rendez compte c'est à dire qu'à
peut-être des jeunes gens qui ont selon
les services de votre on c'est à ça que
vous pouvez penser c'est nous on y pense
on imagine tout comme vous devez y
penser tous les joints toute assez c'est
pour ça qu'il faut passer le message et
enfin je suis là aussi pour ça
aujourd'hui pour les enfants de 2 et
pour les adultes d'ailleurs de témoigner
de protéger les enfants c'était encore
vivante patron il est mort il est décédé
il ya combien de temps il est décédé je
vais enfin je me perds un peu dans le
temps il ya des bons mais pas n'importe
qui
nous vous avez dû vous avez pu lui
parler du dire les choses n'ont jamais
non par contre j'ai parlé un de ses
frères étaient également prêtre
missionnaire qui en sachant ce qui
m'était arrivé
à adresser un courrier que j'ai ramené
je pourrais je pense que c'est important
comme de futurs leaders certaines choses
pour bien comprendre quand même les
enjeux
et oui il est très important et cet
homme-là prêtre donc
a reconnu les faits gérer oralement
parce que il a eu la fin voilà il m'a
dit qu'il avait été informé mais qu'il
ne pouvait pas effectivement parce que
je vois que vous le projeter je peux je
peux effectivement pour donné la gravité
pour moi des options ma part je voudrais
avoir aussi la réaction de l'abbé de la
morandais sur cette lettre qu'ils
aillent voir ce que va vous lire arnaud
c'est la réponse donc je vous dis c'est
ce qui m'a dresse sans du frère vous
l'avez de votre agresseur tout à fait
voilà qui est aussi prêtre également
prêtre est très japonais il était un
café bien sûr prêtre missionnaire
chacun est responsable de ses propres
actes mais il existe aussi une
solidarité entre tous les humains dans
le mal comme dans bien et pour moi cette
solidarité je la ressens fortement
puisque l'on clown magret soeur et mon
frère et que lui et moi sommes en tant
que prêtre au service du christ et de
son église ou aussi j'étais vraiment
peiné et je le reste d'apprendre que
donc cet homme là mon frère tu avait
causé du tort du tort par céder viol
c'est du temps donc tu souffres encore
maintenant alors je te demande pardon du
fond du coeur et germé cette demande
dans les mains de john lui seul peut
effacer le mal commis par les hommes en
guérissant les blessures mais mon coeur
je me permets un choix intéressant ce
que tu lis je te livre vous remettez
donc une carte comme celle là pour moi
c'est important merci que vous devez
connaître c'est la pietà donc
un ami m'a donné la carte ci jointe qui
représente la pietà du xviiie siècle
marie tient sur ses genoux le corps de
son fils jésus descendu de la croix et
on voit la blessure causée par le coup
de lance d'un soldat aux côtés de jésus
c'est par ces blessures que nous sommes
guéris donc qu'est ce qu'il entend par
là en fait en me disant qu'est ce qu'il
entend si les blessures que nous sommes
guéris est-ce que moi les blessures que
j'ai vu que j'ai qui m'ont été sera
dirigée certaine manière cette manière
là que je suis régalé j'ai jamais
compris je trouve ça troublant j'ai reçu
cette lettre la gelée transmise à dacia
c'est ce qui fait assez important je
fais partie des 22 signalements qui ont
été faits par la sia parce
qu'effectivement j'étais hors de moi je
pouvais pas rester dans la
croix